you know my dad told me last night he
said that you got a full ride to Kansas
he just quit why my father didn't like
me very much and someone told him I was
good at basketball he paid a lot more
attention to me and I realized it wasn't
me that he loved it was what I could do
there's been a lot of time earning
myself trying to hurt my father I never
picked up a basketball game
[Music]
we need a new coach Jack you're the
first person I thought of team any good
no in fact the last time they made the
playoffs back when you were playing this
whole team ten kids II wonder why
they're leaving you open it's because I
don't think you could hit the ocean from
the beach
heard you're coaching basketball just my
mind off of those things I understand
you're trying to motivate the team but
we have a code of conduct
I'm working on work harder
[Applause]
I feel like this team's not as bad as
record we have to trust each other we
have to have faith
I just want you to be happy again but
you gotta want it too
don't underestimate the impact you can
have on them you got this know but just
not I'm gonna hear your voice yes or no
yes coach
you nervous I get it
truth is more talented than you but I
got a better coach but I promise you
they are not a better team is they
haven't been through what we've been
through they don't know adversity they
don't know what it's like to get knocked
down I have to get back up again they
don't know what it is to fight
we can't change the past Jack what we
can do is choose how we move forward
[Music]